it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the stories
behind the headline because of that way
during the Raymond Arroyo author of the
wise men who found Christmas Ray the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex are on a war
path boy they sure are Laura in January
Harry's dropping that Tello book but
this week their Netflix documentary
drops which reveals much of their
storyline their truth no one sees what's
happening behind closed doors there was
a war against Megan to suit other
people's agendas it's about hatred it's
about race it's a dirty game
pain and suffering of women marrying
into this institution that's really
frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
[Music]
I feel like I'm watching an episode of
the crown yeah well Meghan Markle didn't
cry this much at Queen Elizabeth's
funeral okay all they do is cry they're
like the Amber Heard of the royal family
they hate what they can't quit but it's
always ugly Laura when you've got
entitled stars who are talking to
millions of people they've got millions
and millions of dollars and they try to
pass themselves off as the victim in
fact tomorrow night right here in New
York City they're receiving from the
Robert F Kennedy uh Ripple of Hope award
for standing up against systemic racism
in the royal family I mean what you
can't make this stuff up and you know
this is all timed with the documentary
in the book it's no wonder why Prince
Charles won't take his calls anymore but
there's more fakery and creepiness here
than that Dahmer movie on Netflix this
shot purportedly showing Harry and Megan
hounded by the paparazzi it's from the
premiere of the last Harry Potter movie
before they were even together yes the
photographers actually confirmed it one
of the guys in the shot and this shot is
from when he was actually with another
girl he looks kind of cute there well
when you see the wide shot he's got
another girl next to him and and now I
guess Harry's going totally Hollywood in
a new video he's actually dressed as
Spider-Man you can't make this up Laura
wait yeah look there he is so maybe he's
auditioning the Marvel Universe he'll be
the Royal Mr Royal or something who
knows
the only Ripple they're a ripple of
tediousness and and banality I mean this
is the Ripple award what well Harry if
it's for Duty Laura they're the Ripple
of nope these two but gold now I'm just
glad they're sacrificing while jetting
off from their Montecito home that they
live in okay they're sacrificing with
the regular people all right but Harry
isn't the only one right dropping the
mask Joe Biden saluted the Kenny Senator
nominees this weekend I sounded like
Biden there Kennedy centered on a race
this weekend well sort of Raymond yeah
well George Clooney YouTube Gladys
Knight they all got perfectly fine
teleprompter salutes from the president
before the event then he got to
Christian singer Amy Grant
tonight we celebrate a truly exceptional
and there's no it's not an exaggeration
a truly exceptional group of
artists we see faith and light we see
Amy Grant
and her Christian songs are played on
repeat in millions of homes across
America
like the
like the greatest
she has she I I I can't get over you
quite frankly
like the greatest dude she writes songs
from her soul
like the greatest do she writes songs
from the soul Laura I tried to replay
that about five times even tried it with
closed captioning it says unintelligible
what's the over under on Biden having
ever heard any Amy Grant song at all I
don't think he's sitting around playing
baby baby I mean maybe I'm wrong that
just pained the Elites in that room
didn't have to hear that you heard the
clap though right
that was bad no no it's fair well if
Lawrence Welk had been you know one of
the honorees he would have had a frame
of reference Amy Grant a little too uh
contemporary for his taste remarkably on
the weekend that saw Revelations about
the FBI attempting to censor the hunting
Hunter Biden laptop story and its
contents guess who attended the Kennedy
Center Honors with Daddy Hunter Biden
Laura he does not miss a major White
House Event when a reporter asked him
about the laptop all they got was a
smile and no response just like the
daddy uh this Administration I guess
fails to see the problem of parading
Biden family members around and using
the White House you know for
introductions it looks like influence
peddling Laura well Raymond China needs
to see him out and about you know China
does not want to see Hunter you know
kept Under Wraps he got to actually see
him Milling about with all the
billionaires in the Hollywood song of
China for the people who missed it Laura
at the at the macron state dinner the
other night there was this moment that
most people didn't see we played it but
I think a lot of people didn't see it
watch this
forces
[Music]
sure but we didn't see her
I follow you
and then he took him up for the
introduction I mean this is so blatant
Laura before I go uh actress Kirstie
Alley tonight we learned from her
children she's died of cancer at 71. uh
Golden Globe winner Emmy Award winner of
course cheers Look Who's Talking a great
loss and many are coming out saluting
her in her passing God Rest her soul and
certainly our prayers Hannity and I
talked about it at the top and you know
she just she just made you Belly Laugh
she had a great delivery and was a huge
gift to us and so we look at we look at
that and remember her what what an
amazing talent Raymond thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else